*static*
*all hail hypnotoad*
*more static*
Velcelcome
My name is Poodiepie
Welcome to..
5 WIERD STUFF ONLINE (dat buzz tho)
ROMANIAN!!
ROMANIAN SLAVES!!! (RS: ya?)
DA FIRST ITEM PLEASE !!! (OK)
(Felix back at his young ages)
YESSS!
Wow, that ish weird item...
that ish veird veri-veird
HIS NAME IS BOOMB? (uh...... Felix thinking good name)
Ok, Ima just scrub him
*moan*
He's got nipples!
They're reall-
can you see im touching his nipple 😢
*nipple touching intensifies*
Now
This item I bought from Amazon
You can buy it for five hundred fuc-
Five hundred
I spent five hundred on this shiet?
Five hundred pounds for this…?
(For a joke)
For a joke that's not even that funny
*bbbzzzzt*
Now he can change his-
oooh
oooohhh
ooOOOAAHHH
OOOH!
And now he is like that guy from darth vade-
err
that guy from Star Wars…
Do you know what I mean?
(No)
No? ;(
aw me neither :|
SO these are made to practice CPR.
(Cardio Pulmonary Resuscitation)
I guess we should…
Do it?
should we
should we try-
should we try it?
PEWDS WANTS TO DIE
…
HE'S DYING!
[rip]
I don't know how to do CPR so
Don't see what the f*cking point is
*exhales into rubber mouth*
*darth vader be like*
*get in there poods*
Oh yeah ;)
You gotta hold the nose
I forgat about dat
*exhale*
*inhale*
*exhales faster*
*INHALES*
*EXHALES*
*presses nipples furiously*
His tits are so f*cking BIG
Five…
Five hundred?
we spent five hundred on this?
At least, you can get him nake-
oouuuuh
OOOOUUUH
yeaaaah :)
are this his…
breasts?
or?
can we get much higheeeeer
so high…
tuu-tuu
*blowjob intensifies*
[All right, uuhmmm]
*static intensifies*
There we go…
We gon fix you up
make you look very pretty :3
HE's CUTE!
WE GON MAKE U PRETTY
we gonna make you…
SHINE
Give him a little bra
Gee? His tits are so far down
Thank you felix
I feel so pretty naw (???)
NEXT
ITEM
PLEASE!
*static brrrzzzzzztttt xdxdxd*
Inflatable limbo stick!
wow
The items gets better every week
We did not spend our entire budget on garble
No! Dat did not happen
*poods gives the succ*
*succ intensifies*
I'm so f*cking tired of inflating shit
Here ya go
HOLEY
SHIET
It's long as…
*boop*
*beep*
[LEAVE ME ALONE!!!]
*derp*
You're like that romanian
You fucking bitch
*bzzzzt*
Parara-rararara-raarararar
OOOOH!!!!!!
HA-HOOW
OOHH!!!!
*all hail hypnotoad*
*poods does a retard*
*intense fight with limbo stick*
*limbo stick is winning*
Alright romaniaaaan
Thank you
Alright…
the f*ck is this
Electro-sex
so this is for your nipples
Test Subject:
Romanian…
*giggle*
a-to-tu-tu-vol-fli
don du tu har
this is for all …
the times
*scream*
OH SHIT
Is it doing it right away?
yehaw
*laugh*
eh-de-de-di
*zzzzzzap*
*electrocution intensifes*
BREAD!
[you too]
yeah…brad
BREAD, com hear
[I don't wanna do it]
Bread, comheaar
Ok well, then just try to–
*gasp*
AHHH!
FUCKING SHIT  FUCK
*zzzzzzap*
*screams in agonizing pain*
That worked?
*evil laugh*
yeah
it is, you need the curry in your body
NOO!!!
AHHHHH! X6
Uuuugh… fuck
oooooh…shit
it's quite nice
*click*
*zzzzzaaap***
*poods gets sudden parkinsons lvl 100*
Ooohh!
AOOOOHH!!
AAAARRGHH!!
MAMA!
AAAARGHGHG!!!
GAAAARGH!!
AARGH!!
*that actually sounded painful*
Manda?
ah
*when my legs fall asleep*
bring in the LOOT CRATE!
*sponsor eagle screech*
Thank you sponsor eagle
hehehehe
hahaha
lootcrate dot com slash pewds
enter the code:
PEWDS
to get ten percent off
what's that¿
*battle cry*
I'm unboxing september's theme:
SPEED!
order before the nineteenth to-
to get the current theme which is horror
ooorgh
dewd!
oooh!
god, ooooh
wooahh!
dewd!
gaba
you are fucking
RIPPED!
is this what it's like to f-
be a dad?
you dress your kids and…
make out with them
ooohh wow
see you always get really "cool" shirts with loot crate!
hoodies, collectable auto, ornaments
we got the flash and the arrow
Please, don't be that, arrow… bitch
awww shit
gawd dammet
lets put it on the shelf for now
*music intensifies*
Batman metal batwing keys change
STEALTH EDITION
ooh
its the bat
the stealth
stealth
okey
it just seems like it would be painful to have these in your pocket
Look at dis!!
you couldn't wea-
you couldn't put this in your pants
it'sa really cool keychain if you wanna rip up your clothes
this is what fashion is all about
you gotta have a nipple out
or you're not… fashionable
Next up, we have "gone in 60 seconds"!
It's uhh
movie
oh, it's a car from the movie
*music intensifies again*
and to top it all up
the big item of this MONTH!
Battlestar Galasticka
galatica
it's battlestar galatica
that's
that's so kool
brad you like these?
yehgimme
alright brad you gottem
*retarded space-travel sounds*
oh! you can make a car out of the box!
that I ruined
cus im an idiot
that's cool
this one's theme is horror
so if you wanna order that …
sounds pretty cool…
I like horror stuff
Halloween is coming up (sp00py)
order before the nineteenth, guys
hurry the fuck up
go to lootcrate.com/pewds
enter the code:
PEWDS
you get ten percent off!
*brllrlrblrblrblrb*
*all hail hypnotoad*
hey poopie
you seem tired
you need some time off?
yes, yes I am- i am a hard worker
i do work really hard on my channel as,
you kno
why, i got something fo' you
wha- what is it?
two tickets to today's SPA!
LETS GO!
*shitty rock music*
*better love story than twilight*
*blblrblrbrl*
aww
*sigh*
okay
is that the thing?
*orchestral music*
okeey
I've arrived at the sauna
*boop* x2
getin da sauna
oh…sorry
sowwy
sowy
*boop*
can u knot?
can u kno-
*poods rages*
*going back into the womb*
*moan*
papa's in heaven
*ziiip*
here we go
*moan*
*mooooooaaaan*
that feels good
I feel…
like a new man
*beep*
what are you doiing?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING??
oh
oh thats hawt
my back is,
BURNING!
they have this thing for my feet
I don't know what it is but I LOVE it
oh its getting
it's gettin a little too hot now
you could turn it down a bit
oh
oh-ho
ooooowh
it's gettin real hawt!
ooooh-ho-hooo!
oooowwh!
boi
ey!
eyyy!
NO!
ah
stahp
this is just, PEWDIEPIE!
*goofy's laugh*
AAAAARTHGHHH!!
fuuck!
yeah
you got it
its me
what are you gonna do?
what are you gonna do bout it, huh?
oooouuughhh!
ughghghg!
argh
*pood growls*
*btbbzbbrbtx*
blah!
thanks for watching this video!
remember to live a LIKE
a thumbsup
it always helps
also, check out our sponsor lootcrate.com-
/pewds
enter the code: PEWDS
and you get ten percent off! (from my butt)
i'm gonna go naw
but thanks for watching
and as always
butt-faced POODS
*fart* (Good for health) *die brofist*
*ugly outro music with that ugly face*